as boba fett temoira morrison is one of
the most feared men in the galaxy but
back home in new zealand why is he still
overshadowed by even more famous members
of his own family keep watching to find
out
temawera morrison's artistic lineage can
be traced to his uncle howard morrison a
legendary musician in new zealand whose
success in voice was so wide-reaching
that he was knighted beyond his music
which was popular across the south
pacific in asia sir howard dedicated his
time and effort to fighting for civil
rights in particular he rallied for
equal education and access for new
zealand's native maori people her enzy
on screen morrison recalled of his uncle
i remember as a young boy growing up we
were always told to stand up and make a
speech stand up and sing a song do this
and do that and when i look back he was
grooming us training us for our journey
however according to a biography of sir
howard written by his son howie jr the
relationship between uncle and nephew
might not have always been smooth
according to the road aurora daily post
the book revealed that sir howard didn't
want to share the limelight and
criticized tamura for his breakout role
in the acclaimed film once were warriors
during an interview with staff temawera
morrison recounted that after being
tapped to play famed australian rugby
coach eddie jones in the 2019 film the
brighton miracle he told director max
mannix are you sure i'm a maori from
rotorua new zealand the maori are
thought to have arrived in new zealand
about a thousand years ago as members of
the polynesian peoples whose ocean going
exploits are epic and as a maori
morrison is part of a collection of
successful polynesian actors blowing
open doors on hollywood this list
includes several a-listers working today
from action stars like dwayne the rock
johnson to mass singer judge nicole
scherzinger the rise of entertainers of
polynesian descent has been a great
stride for inclusiveness
timur morrison is named after his
grandfather who was a professional rugby
player morrison told roto-roo daily post
my cousin terry tapso was born a week
after me whichever one was born first
was going to be called temawera after
our morrison grandfather grandpa
morrison was a member of the new zealand
rugby squad all blacks the perennial
kings of the rugby pitch but the team
isn't without its controversies sir
howard with his group the howard
morrison quartets memorialized one such
incident involving his dad their hit
1960 protest song by old mans and all
black is about how the team wasn't
allowed to play its maori members for a
tournament in apartheid era south africa
plenty has changed since then and the
all blacks have gained global fame for
performing at pregame haka a traditional
maori dance focused on intimidating the
opponent
the average american film goer likely
didn't have any idea who temoira
morrison was before he appeared as jango
fett and then all of jango's clones
however by the time he joined the star
wars universe he had already been
nominated for several awards and even
won a few trophies for acting work in
his native new zealand his portrayal of
jake the mus heek and the 1994 kiwi hit
once were warriors made him a household
name back home but during an interview
with stuff morrison revealed that the
fame he earned through that project
wasn't everything it was cracked up to
be describing the role as a quote
millstone around his neck and expressing
displeasure with the making of the film
it was a lot of hard work and emotional
mayhem people go nutty doing movies like
that it was full on and we never knew
how it was going to turn out the hard
work paid off however as morrison won a
new zealand film and tv award for best
performance and dramatic role for once
were warriors and would later earn a
best actor win for his reprisal of jake
in the film's sequel 1999's what becomes
of the brokenhearted
the original star wars movies had a few
instances where one actor filled the
suit while another voiced it one of
these was of course boba fett with
jeremy bullock wearing the suit and
jason wingreen delivering the voice work
for boba fett's four lines and the
empire strikes back after temoira
morrison played jango fett in body and
voice in 2002's attack of the clones it
made sense that he was tapped to play
boba fett in the mandalorian in the book
of boba fett since boba fett is a clone
of django that raised an issue though
morrison's voice is obviously different
from wind greens so in 2004 lucasfilm
brought morrison back to re-record all
of boba's lines and the empire strikes
back for future releases at least
there's only one django there's only one
django and that's me
temura morrison had long wanted to
return to the star wars universe even
saying in 2017 that he'd want to play an
older captain rex another clone of jango
fett who was introduced in the 2008
animated film clone wars of course that
led to wild speculation that morrison
might actually be able to someday
portray boba fett himself even though
fett seemingly died in the return of the
jedi a pipe dream right well that dream
came true and morrison brought the
bounty hunter back to life in the
mandalorian albeit as an older boba fett
one who survived escaping from the giant
stomach of a sarlacc after that ordeal
and the ravages of time it was
inevitable that the actor would have to
shed his rugged good looks and smooth
voice in order to portray a scarred
battle-worn older boba discussing his
role in the mandalorian morrison told
starwars.com i did rely a lot on the
makeup i spent a lot of the time sitting
in the makeup chair watching what was
being applied and then things just
started to happen organically regarding
his vocal changes morrison said i
thought every now and then he'd hit some
tonal qualities where hey he has been
scarred he has been affected internally
as well so without sounding too false i
wanted to bring a little gravel in there
to give it a bit of timbre
the united kingdom and its commonwealth
nations including new zealand still view
queen elizabeth ii as their queen
despite political independence along
those lines titles and nobility are
bestowed on new zealand citizens just
like in england in new zealand the
nation's royal honors system gives
titles and names people to various
orders and honors as his bio explains
temara morrison was named to the new
zealand order of merit for services to
drama in a 1996 queen's birthday honors
while he was named as a member there are
further levels to achieve at the top are
the titles of dame and knight the level
obtained by his uncle howard morrison
therefore also known as sir howard
perhaps knighthood is destined for
morrison if he continues to captivate
audiences with his acting chops plus
considering boba fett's signature helmet
looks like something worn by medieval
knights it appears to be his destiny
temara morrison is an imposing guy he
earned accolades for playing the violent
jake the must-he and went on to play two
of the most savage bounty hunters in the
history of the galaxy but morrison likes
to also mix things up and show his
softer side once in a while it would be
nice to play just a nice man for a
change without all the hullabaloo stuff
luckily voice acting helps with that of
course he did voice django and boba
fetts both in the films and also in
video games like the star wars
battlefront series but he also voiced
the more nurturing chief tua and moana
the disney sensation with a cast that
features an all-star ensemble of the
world's biggest polynesian actors and
actresses morrison is joined by dwayne
johnson jermaine clement ali'i cravaglio
and nicole scherzing are among others in
the hit movie given his distinctively
tough voice we can only hope he
continues to talk behind the camera as
well as in front of it
in 2009 tamara morrison penned his
autobiography from haka to hollywood
morrison told the new zealand sunday
news that he hoped that his book will
inspire others to reach for the stars
like many celebrity autobiographies it
was ghost written in this case by paul
little morrison told the new zealand
sunday news i'm just going to talk a lot
and paul is going to try and make
something out of it before moving to
auckland i used to perform
professionally in my maori culture
groups i believe there's a formula to
getting to the top and by talking in
this book i might reveal how the hawker
i got to hollywood
temawera morrison is a man of many
talents acting and voice acting are just
the tip of the iceberg while his uncle
sir howard is one of new zealand's most
popular musicians of all time morrison's
father lori was a musician as well so
it's no surprise that in 2014 morrison
released his own album tem which
features covers of classic songs his dad
and uncle liked and used to perform in
an interview with radio new zealand
morrison explained how he used to listen
to his father's records he also
mentioned that when his dad came home
from work he'd shine the old man's shoes
before his father went to perform at a
venue in auckland it's fun to imagine
the elder morrisons jamming out to
american classics and it's impressive
how good tamara covers songs ranging
from midnight special to it's not
unusual on the album morrison also had
another entertainment gig hosting his
own tv shows one of which he believes
might have inspired his record deal
morrison told stuff i think sony must
have seen my tv variety show happy hour
at 9 30 p.m on tv one i said why not do
an album his hosting career may not have
lasted long but he did get george lucas
to appear on his talk show the tem show
not bad for a simple man trying to make
his way in the galaxy thank you also for
toning me there's only been me in a
sheep called dolly i think
it's a common adage that being a child
actor does not necessarily lead to a
successful adult career luckily temara
morrison whose first on-screen
appearance was at the tender age of 11
buck the trend according to enzy on
screen he was cast as a main character
rangi in 1973's rongi's catch after
director michael forlong spotted him
performing for tourists in rotorua in
the movie he plays a kid who along with
three others pursues two escaped
convicts catherine della roach who
reviewed the film for dominion said it
was quote one of the best children's
films ever made his next credit wasn't
until 11 years later the age of 22
playing a rasta street kid on the new
zealand tv series mortimer's patch two
years later he would get recurring roles
on two other new zealand tv series
seekers and adventurer from there
morrison began that long journey to
playing jango fett and blasting onto
movie screens all over the world
temura morrison's first character to
reach a global audience was jake and
once were warriors and his performance
impressed no less than legendary
american film critic roger ebert in his
review of the film ebert wrote in temura
morrison is jake the movie finds a
leading actor as elemental charismatic
and brutal as the young marlon brando he
has instinctive star power and it's his
likability that makes the violence of
his character so shocking morrison
mentioned in a 2014 interview with
screen space that to prepare for the
film he was instructed to watch brando's
performance as stanley kowalski and a
streetcar named desire so ebert's
comparison certainly makes sense what
was unexpected though is that morrison
would end up co-starring with the
legendary brando the island of dr moreau
starred brando as the title mad
scientist in a film that got quite a few
negative reviews morrison who played man
dog hybrid as zizello told screenspace
that he left the shoot because it was
dragging on before a lawyer forced him
back still morrison finally recalls
sharing the screen with one of his idols
telling rotten tomatoes it was great to
see him work see a master work no doubt
someday an up-and-comer will say that
same thing in an interview about the
time they got to work alongside morrison
himself
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]